lo hemos dicho en esta Misión y de hecho
expertos y medios de comunicación
comparan este hecho con lo ocurrido hace
exactamente dos años en Estados Unidos
cuando seguidores de Donald Trump Se
tomaron el Capitolio qué tan preciso es
hacer estas comparaciones
y los sucesos en el Capitolio ocurrieron
El Seis de enero por entonces quién era
presidente Jair bolsonaro defendió el
accionar de los simpatizantes de quien
por Entonces era su colega el presidente
Donald Trump y es cierto bolsonaro nunca
dicinó a lo largo de estos años que
podría ocurrir algo como los que sucedió
hoy entre los hechos y los análisis hay
algunos puntos de Unión por ejemplo la
mayoría de quienes hoy invadieron el
congreso El palacio del la presidencia y
el palacio del supremo tribunal Federal
la mayoría insisto partió del cuartel
general del ejército donde estos
inconformes estuvieron acampados durante
dos meses primer dato el ejército hizo
nada o casi nada para impedir la
invasión tampoco la policía de Brasilia
se esforzó en que los inconformes
destruyeran e incendiaran parte del de
estos tres poderes Qué pasó
evidentemente el flamante gobierno de
Luis Ignacio luna de Silva no tiene el
control ni de las fuerzas de defensa ni
de las fuerzas de seguridad de Brasilia
las que y todo indica sigan respondiendo
o siguen simpatizando al expresidente de
sonaro será que bolsonaro dio la orden
de que ocurra lo que ocurrió Lula en un
mensaje muy breve transmitido desde San
Pablo lo acusó al expresidente y podría
decirse que son estos los efectos de los
constantes ataques de bolsonaro a por
ejemplo autoridades electorales
es probable o por lo menos alguno de los
hechos
ocurridos hace menos de dos horas así lo
indican por ejemplo entre los que
invadieron el supremo tribunal Federal
El palacio del supremo tribunal Federal
en el centro de Brasilia frente a la
plaza de los tres poderes hubo un
inconforme que llegó hasta el despacho
del juez Alexandre de Morales tomó la
toga de esta y se la puso en gesto de
mofa de burla y de indignación Por qué
ese juez porque es precisamente el juez
Alexander Morales quien lleva varias
causas contra el expresidente Jair
bolsonarok y contra sus hijos ahora sí
que cobra más fuerza más sentido aquella
pregunta de bolsonaro volverá a Brasil o
permanecerá en Estados Unidos O acaso
irá Italia cuya ciudadanía está
procurando a propósito señor peñoti Qué
dice el hecho de que bolsonaro ni sus
hijos que son bien activos en redes
sociales hayan pronunciado al respecto
esto alimenta la conjetura de que hay
algún nivel o de simpatía o de
complicidad básicamente del presidente
bolsonaron recuerde usted que hasta el
día de hoy ocho de enero una semana
después de la toma de posición de Lula
por sonaro no reconoce la victoria de
Lula en los comicios del 30 de octubre y
que su hijo uno de los tres el que está
encargado de Los vínculos
Internacionales Eduardo bolsonaro siguió
defendiendo hasta último momento no solo
que no se conociera la victoria de Lula
sino que se hiciera algo parecido a lo
que ocurrió en el Capitolio por lo demás
Eduardo bolsonaro estuvo en Washington
El Seis de enero de 2021 y en la
investigación que se abrió en el
Capitolio hubo por lo menos un párrafo
con cuestionamientos o dudas No una
investigación sobre Eduardo personal